and thank you priia for and Ty for I
mean what's already been a great
conference and the Beautiful location
actually Thomas did an amazing job of
setting up I think um some of the themes
I won't be talking about but that will
be in the background and I'm going to do
the science and Humanities Thing by
giving you a kind of narrative that but
talking about the physics in um in some
ways and I'm going to give a
philosopher's talk by um not asking sort
of what are the causal relations in some
particular domain and how do we know
them but what are causal relations and
the reason that this is an issue has
something to do with the way that
physics developed so there was a time
when causation was thought to be the
sort of objective ordering relation of
the universe so children almost out of
the womb are kind of engaged in causal
exploration we push we pull we learn
what affects what um early science was
all about discovering causal relations
so how did we get to the point in
physics where we were wondering whether
causation was even a part of the
structure of the world well the back
history of this is the same is that at
the same time that physics emerged in
its modern mathematical form causal
structure sort of fell out of it and
this is what Thomas was Al learning was
alluding to so what Newton's Theory
which was really the first theory that
we had in in a form that we would
recognize as a modern physical Theory um
what it gives us is these times these
associations between Global time slices
of the world and they tell us that as he
said if you knew the um sort
of sorry let me back up a
bit
that if you know the total state of the
universe at one time you can calculate
the total State at any other but they're
temporally symmetric so as Thomas said
you can calculate the future States from
past States as surely as you can
calculate past States from future
States they don't have an intrinsic
direction of determination and they
don't say anything about bringing about
they don't tell us that some particular
local event brings about another local
event they don't say anything about the
intrinsic relations of asymmetric
determination between one particular
event between this event and that
outcome there nothing like the sort of
discriminating local relations that we
associate with everyday causal Notions
so Russell writes this paper in
1913 where he says that causation is a
sort of folk notion that should be
pushed aside with the advancing
tides of science it serves an everyday
uh a purpose in everyday life but we
should get rid of causal talk entirely
in a mature science so fast forward to
1979 so 61 years later and Nancy
cartrite points out that actually this
rali this roselan position just isn't
feasible time SYM time symmetric laws
will give us a pattern of
correlations among physical quantities
but we need specifically causal um
information for deciding how to act so
this connects nicely with Samantha's
paper so for example if you're a
doctor um and you notice that people
with fevers are cold so there's a tight
correlation between having a fever and
being cold that doesn't by itself mean
that putting someone in a warm tub is a
good way to break the fever in fact we
know that's not so the way that we know
that's not so has something to do with
the causal relations we need
specifically causal in information to
know whether something is a strategic
route to Bringing about
ends so causal in what causal
information adds to correlations is that
it tells us what are the Strategic
rootes to Bringing about ends so this
point that carite makes is largely
accepted in philosophical
circles people are thinking if causation
isn't
eliminable and it isn't fundamental so
it's not there in the fundamental laws
must be some sort of higher level
structure if we can give an analysis of
causation there's if we can agree what
you say when you say there's a causal
connection people um that then we can
understand what is the physics behind we
can look to try to identify the physics
behind causal relation
but it turns into a sort of compete
moral because people are can't agree on
what the right analysis of causal
Notions is so people in philosophical
literature are trading intuitions about
increasingly artificial hypothetical
cases someone gives a causal an analysis
of causal Notions someone proposes a
counter example it's sort of the
metaphysics version of trolley problems
meanwhile in The Sciences of course
um other than physics causal research is
sort of perceiving unaffected biologists
are doing experiments to see what causes
cell death cell death medical
researchers are looking for what causes
Crone diseases psychologists economists
and social scientists are looking at
what causes Norm change people are
thinking in causal terms they're asking
causal questions deriving causal
conclusions in
practice in science causal hypotheses
are guiding experimental design and
reasoning but there's still this sort of
prejudice against using causal
vocabulary and the formal presentation
of
results um despite what Samantha says I
thought this was at least I mean I
thought that there was this Prejudice
there it's certainly something that
comes out in um Pearl's work I mean he's
deliberately sort of uh addressing this
prejudice
um because there's this feeling that
causal ideas are Uris but the objective
content is really in the
statistics so then Along Comes
interventionism so interventionism what
it does is it provides an analysis of
the content of causal claims and that
turns kind of those informal intuitions
that had been guiding reasoning into an
explicit Theory with a well-founded
logic and
epistemology the formal theory is
introduced variously by Pearl and Gore
at all with philosophical foundations
provided by Woodward basic notion is
causal relatedness between parameters
it's relative to a network and a set of
constraints so a it's causally related
to B just in case there's an invent
intervention on a that affects or
affects the probability of b as the name
indicates the notion of an intervention
is a central innovation so an
intervention is an idealized
experimental um manipulation it's meant
to be a way of manipulating the value of
a variable independently of its own past
causes the intuition is that you
separate the causes from the
correlations by seeing which
correlations persist when you intervene
or when you manipulate a variable in a
network that you're interested in that
is supposed to capture the idea that
sort of getting a hold of a cause of a
is a way of bringing it
about so here's the formal definition I
is an intervention on variable x with
respect to Y just in case I causes x i
acts as a switch for X um for sorry I
acts as a switch for all other variables
that cause X any directed path from y
from I to Y goes through x i is
statistically independent of any
variable Z that causes Y and that is on
a direct path that does not go through X
so the idea is if you have a network of
correlated variables and you want to
know what the causal structure of the
network is what you need to know is
which what happens to other variables if
you get a hold of one of the variables
in the network and you vary it okay so
you manipulate its values and you see
which are the correlations that persist
you can see immediately how powerful an
idea this is for sort of capturing the
core of the scientific concept of
causation any correlations with B that
remain when we intervene on a aren't due
to the information that a
carries about other causes of B but
about influences that pass through a
okay
so this idea is used to generate
analyses of Allied Notions direct cause
singular
causation the framework the
interventionist framework has proven
robust and enormously fruitful it gives
precise and explicit expression
expression to the norms for establishing
causal relations implicit in everyday
practice where
manipulations um or other kinds of
interactions that mimic them are used to
test for causal relationships it tells
us what counts as evidence for causal
claims how one tests for causal
relationships how to extract causal
hypotheses from statistics in a way that
aligns with experimental practice it
provides formal tools or graphical
models for representing causal
relationships and a calculus analogous
to the probability calculus for causal
reasoning so interventionist sort of
sweeps Across The Sciences it's embraced
largely by both experimentalists and
theor theoreticians and becomes a more
or less accepted standard in research so
that's the sort of
backstory but suppose that you're an
objective bystander to this sorry want
to go back suppose you're an objective
bystander and you want to know what
attitude you should take towards um
causation
she put on the hat of the biologist or
the social scientist or the medical
researcher and you might think look
causation has been completely Vindicated
causal facts are real objective facts
they're first in the order of a of um
empirical investigation we can make any
system we like the focus of attention we
test for causal structure by getting a
hold of this or that variable in a
constrained situation manipulating it
and then observing um it's it's its
impact observing the impact of the
manipulation on other variables in the
network so seeing if there's a change or
change in the probability of other
variables in the network this is the
essence of experimental practice
intervening in the practical sense of
course it falls short of being an
intervention in the big eye sense in the
sense that it actually breaks any ties
to past potential causes but we do our
best to randomize connection to
suspected causes um we can always be
wrong so there's a bit of a gap between
what we actually observe seeing a
response to an experimental manipulation
and inferring a causal connection but
that's a part of the epistemology not a
problem with the
ontology so we can release ourselves if
you've got this hat on you can release
ourselves from the shackles of speaking
only in terms of correlations
causal relationships are a perfectly
objective part of the fabric of the
universe so here's what Pearl says this
is largely his attitude he says I used
to think that probabilistic
relationships constitute the foundations
of human sorry I used to think that
probabilistic relationships constitute
the foundations of human knowledge
whereas causality simply provides useful
ways of abbreviating and organizing the
intricate pattern of probabilistic
relationships I now he says take causal
relationships to be the fundamental
building blocks both of our knowledge of
physical both of physical reality and of
human understanding of that reality and
I regard probabilistic relationships as
but the surface phenomena of the causal
Machinery that underlies and propels our
understanding of the world okay so
that's one
attitude but now you put on the hat of
the physicist looking at this in
particular through the lenses of Russell
in
1913 when he wrote that original paper
you might have a different
reaction so let's go back to the the the
physics of Russell's day we assume
classical world and fundamental laws of
temporal
Evolution we Embrace interventionism
moreover as an accurate formalization of
the causal Concepts and the scientific
Machinery that's built around
discovering causal relationships one
might now reason as
follows I understand why limited
creatures investigating in a peace meal
way nature think in causal terms in most
experimental contexts we have a
provisional and a
pragmatically motivated division into
the inside and the outside that is to
say the system that we're interested in
and the outside
world and we know it works well enough
in that setting to treat certain man
experimental manipulations as
interventions but we know that strictly
speaking there are no
interventions no variable is ever as a
matter of physical law separated from
its own past causes the content that
distinguishes causes from
correlations is purely
hypothetical in the sense that it comes
specifically from the treatment of
certain experimental interventions as
manipul ations so it relies specifically
on the IDE idealization that small eye
interventions that is experimental
manipulations that we make in the
laboratory um are interventions with a
big eye that is interventions in the
technical sense that they really do
break ties to all past
causes if we take seriously that we are
parts of
nature then our actions on the system
aren't really interventions
neither a coin flips or random number
generators nor any of the things that we
actually use in experimental cases and
treat as
interventions what there is in nature is
The Unbroken fabric of events when we
absorb our
activity that is the activity of the
experimentor the manipulation of
exogenous variables the setting of knobs
the coin flips the natural experiments
when we observe all of those into the
fabric of nature we find that they are
com that nature is completely described
without residue by The Unbroken pattern
of events
correlations but no causes okay so you
would be perfectly within your rights I
think to to think that interventionism
has in fact Vindicated vessel rather
completely
the
association of intervention with human
manipulation of variables moreover is
not an accident so I'm putting I'm
putting on a hat now I'm arguing in this
vein the treatment of our own
experimental manipulations as paradigms
of intervention is a hold over from
illusions that our own actions aren't
themselves part of the law governed
fabric of events it also moreover
reveals the flaw in cart writs argu
argument against Russell remember what
she said we need causal information for
practical
reasoning be um but that is only because
in that context we imagine that our own
actions are coming from outside the
fabric of the
Universe from outside the causal order
Pearl himself was very clear about the
logic of the situation so this is what
he writes he says if you wish to include
the entire universe in the model
causality disappears because
interventions dis disappear the
manipulator and manipulated lose their
distinction however science he says
however scientists rarely consider the
entirety of the universe as an object of
Investigation in most cases a scientist
carves a piece from the universe and
proclaims that piece in namely the focus
of the
investigation the rest of the universe
then considered out or background and it
summarized by the boundary conditions
this choice of in and outs creates an
asymmetry in which we look at things and
it's that asymmetry that permits us to
talk about outside intervention and
hence about causality and about causal
effect cause effect
directionality Woodward
concurs with pearl on this he says the
special Sciences which are really the
parts of Sciences that are kneed deep
neck deep in causal thinking are open
systems he says such systems are
typically only a small part part of a
much larger world or environment which
is outside the scope of the inquirer's
interest but which can serve as a source
of interventions and a little bit later
he says including the whole universe in
the model leaves no room for
intervention causal Notions are not
applicable to close
systems so when we're investigating
nature the idea here is that we put a
frame around some system and we
investigate it we ourselves are outside
the system system and we examine the
effects of external
input this is essential to experimental
science but the frame of course is
artificial we can always widen the scope
of the frame we can always include more
and more variables in the networks put
more and more explicitly into the
models any exogenous variable can be
made
endogenous and when we carry this
process out this process of widening
the frame to the Limit we do away with
the fiction that we we are outside the
systems the themselves that we study
when we do that we find there are no
interventions we should kick causal
structure away as an understandable but
ultimately eliminable urtic pushed aside
as Russell said with the advancing tides
of
science so I think Pearl and Woodward's
attitude here or line when I'm in a
peran or
woodwardian mood is that well in some
sense that seems like it gets things the
wrong way around what we're really
trying to understand here is the idea of
the non-actual
possible modal content that is what
would happen if such and such has its
most direct empirical significance at
the local level where it's an induction
on an open system response to input
that's what our most basic and secure
modal inferences in science look like
and moreover modal content has practical
significance or practical implications
for the embedded agent who needs to make
decisions about what to do and has to
know what would happen if they did this
rather than
that at the global level so when we push
modal content to the global level both
the Practical and empirical significance
become empty possibilities are what
wholesale alternatives to actuality
external to the world in which we think
and
act modal content at that level seems
degenerate not the basic form not
something that we should try to
understand the actual kinds of modal
content that have practical and
empirical significance
in term in in terms of not what we
should take as basic indeed the way we
give imaginative content to modal
implications at the global level what
the laws entail about other possible
worlds is sort of parasitic on our
understanding of open system so we
imagine God reaching down and varying
the initial conditions of the universe
we reproduce the choice situation in our
imaginations so I've argued these two
sides these two attitudes that one can
take here's the sort of basic logic of
the situation fix the laws of
nature and the global pattern of
correlations entailed by the laws there
are multiple causal models distinguish
from one another only by what they
entail about what would happen if per
impossib we could reach in and Vary the
the values of particular parameters
independent ly of their own past causes
and the per impossibility per
impossibility there means in a way
that's counter to the to um the physical
laws
themselves so there are two possible
attitudes we can reject this sort of
modal overlay that tells you what would
happen if you could per impossibility
reach in and Vary the values of certain
value um variables independently of
those causes we can reject that as sort
of empty and non factual where it goes
beyond claims about the patterns of
correlations entailed by the laws or we
can regard the causal facts themselves
as basic and objective part of the
Machinery of nature treating
correlations as Pearl does as surface
structure and Global laws as kind of
what you get when you carry the division
between an in inside and outside past
its sort of domain of applicability
where you think the causal facts are the
ones that ground facts about global laws
and correlations of life so the reason
this is interesting is imp part because
the division between these two
attitudes re sort of marks a fault line
that runs through science itself between
the sort of practical embedded
interactive view of the experimental
sciences and the sort of descriptive
detached global perspective of the
theorist and it's usually in physics so
of course there's plenty of parts of
physics that are engaged in
experimental science and the philosopher
I should say this God's eye view is very
um it's where the the metaphysician
finds their kind of hospitable
home um so with this in the background
I'm going to do something that's going
to look a little bit like changing the
subject and ask you to think about a
simple mechanical model um of a familiar
kind of system and then I want to go
back and look at this
division um from the outside so in the
descriptive mode and then look at it
from the inside in the decisionmaking
mode and I'm going to suggest that the
reconciliation between these two
viewpoints is going to be sort of
contained in the relationship but
because I have such a short time it's
really going to depend on on you sort of
reading this into the mechanical model
so imagine a vessel floating undirected
in the water okay so it's just a ship
it's floating through the water water in
a local current and we going to
introduce a Rudder into this
system um and at first the rudder itself
is just a part of the ship but I'm going
to introduce a knob that's sort of
mechanically linked to the position of
the rudder okay so the ship is kind of
pushed around by the local current but
what the knob does is it provides a way
for us to introduce a new mechanism to
control the position of the rudder
so this mechanism is generic we can
splice in anything that we like here we
could have for example a little
metronome that swings back and forth to
control the position of the rudder
introducing a periodic motion into its
movement we could have it on a timer so
that it switches Direction at an
appointed hour we could tie the knob to
the leg of a little dog that runs around
the surface of a ship we could Outsource
it to a sort of
control uh station on Shore whatever we
like we can now splice in anything that
we like into the Dynamics of a ship
that's going to canide the use of the
knob control the position of the rudit
position of the rudder is now an
independent degree of Freedom that
complicates the motion of the ship it
becomes a locust of control that can be
exploited to steer the ship by setting
its value so that in conjunction with
the expected value of other observable
with other degrees of freedom it sort of
produces the desired
motion this is all a very familiar sort
of schema for design a smart designer
who wants the ship to remain on due
course will know how to adjust the
position of the rudder to keep it on the
path given the local
current so let me spell this out a
little more
explicitly we're going to assume here
that the Dynamics of the ship is
effectively classical so the laws are
local they're Markov they're
deterministic the way that the ship
responds to the local current depends on
all of the internal variables including
the position of the rudder so the
position of the rudder is not singled
out dynamically here but if all of the
other variables are in fact fixed across
the range of situations that we're
interested in on the time frame that
we're interested in then the only moving
part is the rudder and the knob that
controls it okay so this is just a fact
about the Dynamics I said if we fix all
of those other variables then the the um
position of the r acquires a special
position but we can actually exploit
this fact about the the Dynamics by
putting in place constraints that keep
the other variables fixed um in the
setting that we expect the ship to oper
operate and by that I mean we can
literally like bind the parts of the
ship into a fixed configuration do what
we need to do to constrain the values of
those other variables across the range
of circumstances that we're interested
in the knob then has a special position
as the only under those conditions as
the only active internal
variable we can use it so that in
conjunction with expected values of
exogenous variables so wind current
temperature we can use the position of
the rudder to
um to realize intended movement of the
ship so how does that work well let's
suppose there's a little onboard
computer with a programmed
destination the computer gauges the
local current calculates where the
rudder needs to be to keep it on due
course and sets it accordingly Okay so
what do I mean when I say it calculates
where the Ruder needs to be I mean that
again this is just making a little bit
more explicit things that you already
know I mean that it predicts the
expected values of different settings of
the Ruder and chooses based on the not
the expected value the expected outcome
of putting the Ruder in different
positions and calculates uh and then
bases its decision on the
assessment if we want to predict the
motion of the ship it's not enough to
know as a matter of physics it's not
enough to know the local current we have
to also know the position of the rudder
the position of the rudder is being set
by this internal computational cycle so
effectively we have to know if we want
to know where the ship is going we have
to know where the ship wants to go and
which way it should go
given the
destination all of this should look
perfectly straightforward
I'm just making again a little more
explicit things that you already know
instinctively so then we can use this as
a schema for um a system that steers its
way around the world so the boat itself
is a purely mechanical
system and we're assuming that the laws
are deterministic so there's no magic
here the onboard computer is
just the onboard computer is just
electricity flowing through transistors
the highlevel design of the computer
directs that flow so that functionally
it processes information and performs
computation the computational
description here is just a compact way
of solving the ordinary dynamical
equations exploiting what we know about
the emergent behavior of the computer so
whatever you want to say here about the
relationship between hardware and
software say it splice in your
philosophical views about this the
system supports two levels of
description a computer is an actual
machine so it's a mechanical system um
that we can get to perform any virtual
tasks so we can that falls within sort
of the realm of computation by
appropriate
programming so now let's look at the
computational cycle that the computer is
running through so the ship has a single
goal is charting a course towards some
Target location T and it has a single
degree Freedom here the position of the
rudder what does the computer
do what should it do if it wants to
reach its goal what's the right
computation for it to perform in the
service of reaching its goal well it
treats the rudder as a free variable
calculates the expected effects of
different settings given the local
currents and makes a choice based on the
assessment of the
outcome that of course is the same form
as what we do in Practical reasoning we
have more complex goals more degrees of
freedom and so on but the control
structure here is no different so when
you ask like sort of what should I do in
a paradigmatic choice situation there's
a range of available actions ways that
you could set the degrees of freedom
that you have voluntary control over you
treat the action as a free variable
and you ask what would happen if I A or
B or C and then your decision is based
on assessment of the
outcome so the suggestion back when we
were ask when we were talking about
causation was somehow that the treatment
of our own actions as a free variable as
an intervention in the technical sense
um in the context of choice is a sort of
artifact of illusions of agency the
imagin
that our own actions aren't part of the
natural Fabric or the causal order of
not taking seriously that is to say that
we ourselves are parts of nature I want
to point out here that there's actually
No Illusion involved indeed it's
precisely because we are part of nature
that our choices appear in this setting
to us um as free variables and the
reason is that is because our choices
are set by the outputs of those sorts of
computations so let's go back and
consider the
ship and it it's might help here I don't
know how to do this to see this drawn
out I want you to ignore these I
couldn't get a diagram that didn't so
ignore those
connections there okay what I'm assuming
here in the background as not
represented in this diagram I'm assuming
all of the scaffolding that supports the
everyday sort of macroscopic environment
so I'm assum assuming all the stuff that
that Thomas talked about I'm assuming a
thermodynamic gradient I'm assuming the
temporal asymmetries that come with it
I'm treating as constraints values of
variables that stay fixed um for the
purposes of predicting real time motion
so the only things that are explicitly
represented here are variables that
change in real time um over the course
of the ship's
motion and that matter for the motion of
the ship
so six here is the decision that sets
the position of the rudder so the
decision here is something that's going
on board that's happening on board in
real time and it's um being done by the
computer eight is the boats is the
motion of the boat five and seven are
sort of thing exogenous variables like
currents wind speed temperature
variables that in conjunction with the
reder position determines the motion of
the ship and then just for Simplicity
here I'm going to elide the distinction
between sort of the output of the
computation and the actual mechanical
setting of The Ruder um it won't matter
here can make that distinction if you
want as long as they're highly
correlated we don't assume that the
decision has no causal history we
explicitly don't we take it for granted
that the decision does have a causal
history it's represented here explicitly
by all of these factors so here's the
dec here's the decision here's the rud
setting and that's the ship's
motion the only thing that we assume is
one that the decision makes a difference
to the ship's Motion in the sense that
given the other variables so
given five and seven and any other
relevant exogenous variables
conditionalizing on six has a
probabilistic
effect on the ship's motion and two that
the decision is
determined by the output of a
computation that assesses its
effects
okay in so far as there is a line of
influence here oh shoot
I as there's a line of influence on the
ship's motion that passes through the
decision the decision will screen those
factors off it's going to screen off all
of the factors whose influence passes
through the decision if the system is
trying to predict its own
behavior it's going to realize that
there are multiple consistent Solutions
depending on what gets filled in for
six and that's where the freedom comes
from its own actions are going to appear
to it as free
variables so if you look at the diagram
go
back if you look at the diagram you'll
see that what
sorry if you look at the diagram you'll
see that What's Happening Here is that
you're making a decision about how to
set the rudder so you're making a little
calculation in your head you're sort of
running a little internal simulation of
a process that that simulation feeds
into so if you are trying just from your
position at six to predict the motion of
the ship there's going to be a little
bit of self- reference implicit built
into the
computation when you try to
compute you're going to hit a
conditional branching that depends on
the output of the computation
itself that's where the multiple
Solutions comes
from that's what opens up the space for
thinking strategically the system says
to itself how do I use the probabilistic
effect of six on eight to my advantage
how do I use the line of influence that
passes
through here to push the downstream
probabilities in a direction I like and
to do that it needs to assess the
probabil IC effect of six on eight when
six is treated as a free variable so it
needs to know sort of what the decision
itself adds to influences that bypass
the decision on the motion of the ship
okay you can think of the process
between six and eight let me go back you
can think of the process between six and
eight
here as consolidating all of the
influence that comes from six's past and
making a decision about where to
deposit that
influence eight of course is just one
among the factors that jointly determine
the ship's
movements there's a ton of physics
that's going on here that's determining
the values of these other variables so
the currents the wind speed and so on
but the process is designed to
effectively hack that physics by
determining the expected values of those
and saying what do I need to do here to
produce some Target state in the future
so it's factoring them into its decision
about what to
do so where is all this leading all of
this is leading to the idea that look
from the outside there are no
interventions there's just the unbroken
fabric of nature but from the inside
there are interventions simply for
self-re differential
reasons it's an expression of the fact
that some of what happens in nature is
stuff that what we is stuff that we do
and that's where causal thinking has its
home tileology acting for m is
underwritten by the recognition that
decisions have an effect that we can
anticipate and can be used strategically
to shift down stream probabilities in a
favored Direction whatever contribution
your decision makes to the determination
of Your Action the contribution is
measured by treating it the contribution
is measured by treating it as a free
variable and you need to know what that
contribution is if you're going to use
it strategically so there's nothing
diluted about treating your own actions
your own voluntary actions as free
variables in the context of deliberation
that's what that creates the need for
causal information and this is I think
the right way to reconcile that sort of
inside outside View
great thank you so
much we are running late so I will um I
two quick questions before we break for
a
coffee it's a naive comment but I mean
I'm just wondering first if this
discussion conflates uh the difficulty
of establishing a causality and the
absence of causality
fundamentally right and um so this is
the first question and I guess I will
just stand that so I'm not sure why you
say that oh okay so then to expand say
you have you you mention consistent
continuously this fabric of
universe uh and in this fabric of
universe say your talk is like a tiny
spec and the question is how those specs
are connected to each each other uh the
one possibility is they uh influence
each other which implies a
causation because the alternative
opposite of causation is not correlation
the opposite is Randomness to me uh so
then if uh the fabric is complex say if
the fabric the element is simple you can
figure out what we do in the laboratory
easily if the fabric is complex and the
links are Al so complex you may just
face the P the situation you cannot
Define what what the causal relations
between those millions and millions of
notes are but it doesn't imply by itself
that they are not influence each other
which the denial of causation would
imply so it doesn't deny that so the
you're you're I wasn't giving and if it
doesn't deny it then all this talk that
there's no cation is I mean I would say
empty so the the motivation comes from
being a fundamentalist about the
physical laws and try and sort of from a
position of the kind that wrestle Health
right so you say what there what I
believe in is fundamental physics and
I'm trying to find a place in a world
that is fundamentally determined by
physical laws for causation um so if
you're starting from the point of view
where you say look I understand why we
reason causally and so on but that's
partly because of contingent limitations
and it's a convenient juristic but what
there is in the fabric of nature is just
what the laws tell us so you know I
haven't given an argument for that
position it's a starting challenge um it
was the challenge that I was starting
with so in in in effect it's asking for
you tell me why I should believe in
causal
relationships okay to quick question
this is really quick but it just it
seems to me you had on the screen in the
middle there are these two attitudes and
that that rises out of Russell yeah
seems it's just a false dilemma right
the the options seem to be Russell says
I don't see causation in the laws of
physics so there's no causation and the
other one is well no causation is basic
and fundamental you want to say Russell
you don't see pianos in the laws of
physics either okay but they're real
okay they're they're really real they're
not fictive and they're not fundamental
either right so they're lots of things
in the world that are neither written
into the laws of physics nor merely
fictive all the emerging things tables
and chairs and everything so it just
seems like a false dilemma when you set
it up that way why can't causation be
like that it's as real as a piano yeah I
understand so this is the way the
dialectic went you start by think
assuming that causal relations are
fundamental then you get the physics and
you don't see them in the fundamental
physics so then the back I then the step
backward is okay so what are causal
relations as soon as we have an analysis
then we can understand the physics that
underwrites them people sort of T you
know cast around for an analysis it
takes a long time interventionism comes
along and that seems to that seems to
coales people around the idea that this
is the right analysis for causal
relations so how do we this is the right
analysis of the content of causal claims
what do you saying about the world when
you say there's a causal relationship
analyze in terms of of uh what happens
under hypothetical interventions and
then the challenge reasserts itself
because you say what is a hypothetical
interv vention an intervention is
something that explicitly seems to go uh
you know uh is is counter legal it's
counter to what the laws entail so that
reopens the position for a raelan point
of view so that's the way that the the
dialectic went I mean I you know it went
very quickly and it and of course I
ignored lots of positions along the way
but I really do think that um this is uh
something that to me captures the the
the heart of the conflict between two
ways of thinking about causal
relationships let's thank J for
[Applause]
very